three six mafia and bone thugs and
harmony
uh they got into a fight during their
verses yeah busy bone busy yeah yeah
what do you think about credit or some
[ __ ] like that he's got like some mental
health issues oh no so he came on stage
and was just like stop making fun of me
or don't make fun of me or some [ __ ]
like that and then you just threw a
[ __ ] bottle of whatever at the at 3 6
and then that was it no no no
somebody from three six said suck my
dick oh that's what it was and that is
you're right fighting
right we've seen that on this podcast
yeah that [ __ ] that's a fight starter
now it's funny because he got so
offended by it but he doesn't
necessarily throw like a man so
i mean he threw like you suck dicks yeah
yeah yeah that's right that's what
you're trying to say
but rappers are known for not being able
to throw objects like 50 throwing the
baseball and [ __ ] like that we're not
throwing this past day shouts to pastor
had a still shot of how busy bone wound
up and it's so [ __ ] embarrassing
what he did
yeah like this yeah not like you're not
all the way back like halfway like that
it's a [ __ ] rough one dude yeah it's
a rough one it's a shame man i really
liked uh
three six mafia
and also bone thugs and harmony yeah
that's our age group you didn't like
them it's bone and biggie biggie
biggie it's spawning baby
it's boring
let's ride let's ride let's ride
yeah yeah
i'm been dangerous
oxygen
damn bro i almost had that [ __ ] too i'm
sorry i got a couple songs in the
rolodex bro i got an nba young boy song
that's fire oh [ __ ] hit it hit it you
want me to do the nba
no you don't you all wanted me to do
that we not ready yeah not ready maybe
later in the park
you